with just over two weeks until the
midterm elections hundreds of
jurisdictions are still reporting a
shortage of poll workers why big reasons
concerns about their safety the FBI
recently said that seven states continue
to see unusual threat levels against
people who run the elections that
includes Pennsylvania where Ed O'Keefe
spoke to Philadelphia officials who are
really racing to fill Staffing Staffing
gaps rather ahead of election day he
joins us now Ed I see why people are
afraid you see what's happening at the
polls good morning to you
yeah Gail good morning good to see you
and they had to take a dramatic step
here in the City of Brotherly Love by
installing bulletproof glass at the
place where they actually count the
ballots on Election night another
example of the kinds of threats that
workers are facing across the country at
the polls and with just 18 days to go
cities like Philadelphia are still
looking for people to step up
leave a shout out to the election board
workers across our country because it's
a hard job it's a thankless job
Philadelphia City Commissioner Omar
sabir says it's part of his job to be a
cheerleader for elections it's also up
to his office to help hire the more than
8 000 poll workers the City of Brotherly
Love will need to run elections smoothly
people don't understand that the average
poll worker they're the ones that
actually administer the elections in
hopes of filling the jobs the city
recently boosted pay for poll workers
250 bucks to work more than 12 hours on
Election Day the first major raise since
the 1970s needed to address the growing
challenges of the job so when people say
things like elections are fraudulent and
things of this nature it's really a slap
an indictment against America a survey
by the nonpartisan Brennan Center says
nearly a third of Elections officials
know of at least one colleague who left
the job in part because of fears for
their safety increased threats or
intimidation after the 2020 election Al
Schmidt is a former Republican City
Commissioner who stepped down earlier
this year following repeated threats
against him and his family including
threats to kill his children well you
don't expect one day to be responsible
for running elections in a democracy and
have to have police go with you when you
take your kids sledding in the snow and
when you go to the grocery store Schmidt
says the threats of violence and added
political pressure is transforming what
was once a much lower profile form of
Public Service typically campaigns
compete against other campaigns
candidates run against other candidates
and the election administrators are
really the referees of it all so it's an
unusual situation to have the referees
getting punched and getting tackled
we're actually tracking right now about
4 400 jurisdictions across the country
that we've been in touch with that are
still looking for folks James slusser is
with power the polls we're growing the
next generation of poll workers a
non-partisan group that launched during
the 2020 election cycle to help find
poll workers during the pandemic how
important are poll workers to the
Democratic process oh they are the
essential workers of our democracy
there's a lot of focus around the
polarization of our elections but the
folks who are signing up with us I read
the messages that some people send in
and they're like I don't care who people
vote for it's just about everybody in my
community being able to be able to cast
their ballot forgive my cynicism but
those people still exist they are
signing up every single day so they do
still exist but Schmidt worries if the
current threat environment continues
it'll keep forcing out qualified
election workers the danger is that
we'll lose experienced election
administrators more than we already have
and they'll be replaced by either people
with less experience so more likely to
make a mistake when administering an
election and doing it in an environment
where any mistake is perceived as being
intentional and malicious in some way do
you think the guys that got together in
that building back there would make of
all this well they're watching over us
there was a real burden that I know my
colleagues and I fell a real obligation
to make sure that we stood up for
democracy
now it's been just over a year since the
justice department launched a new
elections threats task force to look
into threats against elections officials
and those that work the polls they're
facing criticism however for so far just
coming up with one conviction the
justice department tells CBS News it
continues to actively investigate
threats across the country to poll
workers and expects to have additional
prosecutions Nate but look if you're
someone who's young and interested there
are ways to get out there and volunteer
and there are cities across the country
who need your help wow we need those
volunteers Ed thank you yeah now you can
add poll workers to the long list of
essential workers it makes me actually
sad that it's come to this that now you
have to have bulletproof glass at
polling place well you hear about the
threats but then you you see what people
are saying yeah it's just vicious I hope
people are watching I hope they
volunteer yeah